hey guys it's just dude and today I'm so
excited because the new ECG feature on
the Apple watch was recently released
and this is something that I've been
waiting for for I guess since the Apple
watch officially came out this is the
Apple watch series for and this is only
available on the series for I'm sure you
guys saw many of the videos that I did
about the Apple watch but if you didn't
I'll put a link in the description and
an annotation if you want to check that
out I posted that a while ago but today
I'm gonna go through and show you guys
how to activate the ECG on your Apple
watch but the first thing that you have
to do is make sure that your Apple watch
and your phone is updated to the latest
OS so once you've updated your watch and
your app go into the heart and this will
take you into the heart health and this
will have a little setup screen I
already did it
so here's may look a little bit
different you want to turn on the ear
regular rhythm so that will notify you
if your watch detects anything that's
irregular I also have on my high heart
rate my little heart rate you can go in
here you can view your recorded ECGs and
health this will all be recorded inside
of the health application so here it is
I've only taken one ECG so far when I
set this up this morning so I wanted to
show it to you guys again and show you
how it works you'll install the ECG app
onto your watch face and there is right
there it's definitely recommended that
you do sit down and you kind of stay
relaxed while you're doing this so I'm
gonna sit down under my table I'm gonna
give you a demo of what it does look
like over here but just know that I'm
sitting down doing this
and there is my reading right here and
this automatically gets sent to my
iPhone you can add symptoms or just
click done and then be here on my phone
you can see that the ECG recording is
available so then we open that up I can
get the reading of what my ECG was and I
can export this as a PDF to my doctor I
don't have a doctor I should probably
get one so that I can send them my PDFs
it's also cool because it shows you what
the device was that was reading it Apple
watch which watch version I just I'll
just show you guys this and how to set
it up in case you were curious because I
did have a few people that question how
to set this up on Twitter and I'm pretty
excited because the Apple watch for me
has changed the way that I track my
fitness and it's one of those things
that you definitely don't need to have
it but for me I feel like the Apple
watch has motivated me it has kept me
accountable for the fitness goals that I
have set even though I haven't set
specific goals just doing these
competitions with my friends has made me
realize that okay everybody else is
moving today Justine you better get your
butt up and go do things and this past
year Fitness has been a huge part of my
life because I really feel like I needed
to get my life together there was a
point in time last year where I probably
felt the absolute worst that I've ever
felt in my entire life and I knew that
something had to change and a lot of
things changed as crazy as that sounds
the Apple watch sort of did play a part
in that and you know it doesn't have to
be the Apple watch for you it could be a
Fitbit it could be anything that sort of
keeps you accountable but for me it was
the Apple watch and my friends and just
a lot of different changes that I had to
make and sometimes those changes are the
most difficult thing that you have to do
but it's one of those things that you
know that you need to do and you just
got to go and do it get your butt up off
the couch go outside and start doing
some activities and just keep moving and
I know it's crazy but to say that the
Apple watch changed my life it was a
catalyst for sure I mean I was the one
that had to put those actions into
motion the Apple watch kept me
accountable and it is really great to go
back and see where I started from like
how
some of these hikes were for me in the
beginning so for me being able to
quantify all of those things is really
amazing so hopefully that this could
inspire you either get an Apple watch or
to get something or even just to get
moving like you don't have to have a
device to do it but it does really feel
great to be able to actually see the
numbers in front of you and be like yeah
I'm actually making progress I'll see
you guys in my next video let me know if
there's anything else that you would
like to see me make I'm starting some
new stuff in 2019 which is actually
crazy it's coming up soon so I'd love to
hear from you what are your favorite
videos of mine and hopefully I can make
some more of those and until then I'll
see you guys later don't forget to
subscribe if you like this video click
like and leave me a comment below and
let me know what your new year's
resolutions are and don't worry if you
didn't make those new year's resolutions
this year there's always next year and
it doesn't have to happen in the new
year it happen anytime you just have to
have the will and the motivation to make
those changes so that's it I'm just I'm
just talking to those points oh my
sweater has holes in it I paid extra for
these holes that's how you know there's
a problem
[Music]